a lot of your fans like about the
documentaries are your voiceovers you do
those voiceover it's kind of explaining
what you were feeling at the time you
know I felt so and so was tiring of my
questions so I decided to leave talking
about yeah well what about what about
the voiceovers though you well you know
you know what I'm talking about that
that thing that you do I've got confused
by Graham's question it occurred to me
that perhaps he was trying to lure me
into one of his comedy bits attempt to
disarm him I decided to say nothing new
silence caught me off guard I decided to
play it cool and drink some wine this
was getting awkward with Graham simply
embarrassed or was it true he does have
a drinking problem
did my fellow guests felt as
uncomfortable as I did
I shared Louise discomfort I'm sound
distracted and it was a long time since
it asked me a question about my book why
is everyone talking to themselves
jeez they're really flogging this comedy
bit when is Graham going to introduce me
[Music]
you